the broadcast is now starting all
attendees are in listen only mode
good afternoon we are live now
hello good afternoon everybody welcome
to our webinar
and today we will try to give you some
more background
on a very interesting project the fiber
rollout project
um uh focused on on what proximism
belgium is
is trying to do with the intention to
cover more than 2 million homes
with a fiber to the home connection
within the coming years
and we'll dive into some real life
experiences and practical
uh lessons learned on the innovative and
automated planning and design process
i'm very honored to be uh to have with
me here
uh very distinctive speakers so uh here
braulon's he's domain manager
uh and part of the fiber network program
at proximus
uh he will guide us through a lot of the
practical
aspects and the daily things that are
happening within proximus on this side
and patrick del quanye the director of
network engineering and operations at
proximus
will give us some more insights in the
early stage of the webinar
on the whole proxima's project and
strategy i myself am raf mersman i'm the
ceo of comsol
and i'm also joined by my colleague
kelly furnier
our head of client acquisition so we
hope we will be able to give you some
interesting content
in the next hour or so we foresee about
45 minutes
for the presentation part and we'll
treat q a
at the end as usual i guess you're uh
most of you are familiar with the
webinar
formats you can leave your questions in
the platform
and we'll pick up some of those
questions as time permits
towards the end of the session you also
see on this first
slide um that there is a qr code uh with
also a url um so this is will be used
throughout
the webinar for an online polling live
polling system
um so we invite you to scan the qr code
or or go to that url
and leave that page open because it will
automatically refresh with new questions
as we
as we go along um and
with that let's have a first uh
test of the polling system so um
normally if you go to the url you should
see um
an option to leave the or to select the
type of company that you are part of
whether it's a network operator
consulting firm etc
and we indeed see answers coming in
as we go so that is already very nice
that
that seems to work very well and you are
finding your way
so feel free to keep on adding it's a
very nice spread
um so that is also interesting to know
and uh you will you can keep on adding
your responses now
but you also automatically will see new
questions popping up there
as we go now with that i would like to
hand over
to patrick del cuando for an
introduction on the proximus project
public floor is yours thank you for the
introduction
so good afternoon everybody so i'm very
very honored today to
introduce you our company proximus it is
fth concealed webinar
proximus is the belgian
telecommunication operator so we are
operating
both in belgium but also on the
international scene
via our daughter company biggs and we
are leading provider on the fix
and mobile networks so as well as the
ict services
basically our strategy here relies on
four pillars
the first one all starts with solid
foundations and in this this is the
networks
and our mission is to build the best
gigabit network
for belgium in both fixed and mobile
secondly we want to operate as a digital
native company
what does it mean it means to have a
digital interaction with our customer
but also starting using digital tools
also in the network production
environments and in that respect you
will see that comsoft
is bringing an high degree of automation
thirdly we want to grow up profitably
and this
we do with this partnership you will see
this also in the fiber deployment
and this we do this for co-development
and co-investments
finally we want to play on a really
important societal role
by bringing sustainable solutions green
solution
and also by caring for the digital
inclusion that's basically the fourth
blocks of the approximate strategy
now if i have the control
[Music]
okay let's start with the first pillar
which is basically about the networks
okay
yeah when looking on this first pillar
which is
building the best gigabit networks for
belgium our approach is
threefold i would say first we want to
offer
any service on both mobile and fixed
network
you do see the variety and triple play
but also the iot
and so on secondly and it's
special for an operator let's create as
from the start
a really open network open api which is
by design scalable
to our retail customer residential
and professional but also all the other
license operators the olos and the
virtual mobile
network operators as well as industrial
partners like the
institution or european commission
airport
and so on so we want also to create
not the network but the best network in
fixed and mobile
the totally best network in capacity in
symmetricity
in latency in quality and in
resilience so that's basically what
we are building as foundations
okay let's start now with the fiber this
will be our focus today
so fiber fiber for belgium where are we
today
in belgium few words first about belgium
belgium is a small country
thirty thousand kilometers per square
kilometer
eleven million inhabitants which
represent in fact
six million ohms and business that's
quite
challenging uh environment i would say
on an urbanistic point of view
you do see the you do see the diversity
uh i would
say the complexity that we have to
address that's not a usual country
that's quite complex uh to be honest
we deployed the fiber both uh in wall
mounted
so on the facade as we see and
underground
and this we do with partners i will see
this afterwards
the end goal is to really switch off the
copper
after the deployment so on a relatively
relatively short time
time frame we want to really switch off
the copper in every
fiber zone
yeah now if we look at the status today
so belgium today is not known as the
ftth country not yet
i would say belgium
nearly among the last in the european
countries we have about 10 percent of
national coverage in ftdh
today but you have decided to accelerate
the plan
and to move massively but john as you
have seen maybe in the last
uh ftbh council report is really not the
fastest growing market in europe
we did times 1.5 on one year in terms of
deployments
and we are tend to cover 70 percent of
the population
by 2028 it means 4.2 million on ombuds
this concretely means that every year we
will cover we have to cover
10 percent of the country every year it
represents about 6 billion euro
investment
over the years to come and looking now
at the graph that you do see here that's
about yearly volumes as you see and
those here reviews
you see a doubling of the deployment
pace year over years
since 2017. so we double double double
and
we will reach and we will culminate
above
thousand home passed a year meaning ten
percent of the country
or one home one hours every 15 seconds
we are fully on track with the plan
that's a massive that's exponential i
would even say
and that we will do on two ways first by
deploying ourselves
on all assets that's 2.2 million home
parts that we want to deploy that we
will deploy
and that's an additional 2 million home
pass that we will do with partners
with the joint venture that we have
created fiberglass on the north
and there is a second the joint venture
on the source path
so in total for the two million on past
representing
at least 70 percent of the country
and this we want to uh do for all the
players uh so
that's an open network we have today
already more than 30
will save these and some still incubate
incubating
now let's look at what we need for to do
this
but typically to build this network we
really need
a very old machinery and this both in
field production trenching splicer
blowing and so on
but also in design activities and for
the design activities we have chosen to
work
with comsoft comes off with its powerful
design
engine console is basically a belgian
company
created from a spin-off of the
university of ghent
and proximity concepts are cooperating
uh since many years already
we have chosen becomes of fiber products
uh
to design the fiber networks in an
automated way in a quite complex
environment you will see
but not only that's automated which is
important to uh to keep the pace
but that's automated and the design that
is out of the system
is made in a such way that we really
have the most
cost optimal design by reusing existing
infrastructure and optimizing
everything we do use this for the fth
brownfield mainly for the earth since
three years now but we also complement
uh the the application with the concept
five of product
in the greenfield environment in other
fiber
diversity uh so that's no
rough uh that will be maybe explain
better than i do uh
the history of comsoft and where you are
positioned on these markets
yes thank you very much patrick for your
kind introduction also of of yeah the
proxima's project but also of course of
indeed
just indeed a few words for those people
who may not know
comes off as well we are actually a
company that's been around for
23 years now and since the start we've
always been
focused on developing software for
network planning of telecom networks
and then more specifically since 2004
with a strong focus on the fiber to the
home networks
so we have a long history in this and
have also been very active in this
market we are
uh with more than 50 employees spread
over two offices
again toronto and um we have
been involved in and i'm very proud to
say more than 200 fiber projects across
more than 50 countries
worldwide making us quite experienced in
the different flavors of fiber rollout
projects
important to notice that we are a
software company so we develop
and we implement and deliver the
software
with our clients but it doesn't mean
some people prefer design of networks as
a service
for that we have a growing network of
certified
design partners who can use our software
to also
deliver that as a service now
what is our software about you could
look at it basically as a kind of
calculation machine
calculation engine um that will automate
a lot of decision making in
how your network could be uh constructed
but to feed it you need to put in a lot
of data we'll
we'll talk about a bit more for the
specific proxy in this case but it's
a lot of gis based data
roads buildings etc and you also need to
specify your
design rules and your unit prices and
with all that input and and you can
obviously also
tune that input the software will
suggest to you an optimal
uh network in a highly automated way
but it's not just the topology and the
map it's also a whole database full of
every little number that you can think
of
and of course based on those detailed
numbers you can
create all kinds of summary views that
give you a lot of insights on the costs
of deploying the fiber network
now um kelly you talk regularly to a lot
of our clients and uh
involved in these activities and maybe
you can explain a little bit
how they see the value of our software
yeah indeed um we we of course as you
would expect we we talk
regularly to our clients and try to get
um information from from the horse's
mouth
uh so to speak and it's really that what
they
tell us is the combination of the power
of automation
uh and to optimize the designs
uh to eventually find a constructable
design right because we always
we all know here that it's not
necessarily the cheapest design that
will be
buildable in the field so you don't
necessarily only look
at the cheapest way to design an area
but you have to build it uh design it i
should say in a way that that's going to
be
doable in the field right so our clients
really tell us
uh it's about speed so they they
constantly come with different time
savings of whether it's half the time or
90 speed gains uh in their end-to-end
process um there's about a five to ten
percent
cost uh effectiveness gain
in the build so not only in design costs
but it's very important to mention that
uh the savings are in the construction
phase and we know that the five and ten
percent
is considerable cost um really brings
value especially in the
quality and uniformity of the designs um
and uh
lastly one important point is the cost
control so so
limiting the variations between
estimated costs in the planning phase
and design phase
and the as built costs uh so the actual
fuel cost so that's
that's a big that's a big win
um so yeah having said that uh maybe we
can look at
uh more information from our attendees
and
going to another poll question we'd like
to know what
which of these statements best describe
your current
fttx planning and design context now
more than one answer apply so i would
encourage you to choose
the answers all the answers that would
apply to you so either you do
manual planning and design today maybe
you already use an automation software
maybe you're simply interested to find
out more about automation maybe you're
not convinced of course
that is also possible um
and many of you could not simply not be
involved yet
in planning and design activities but
which may come with time
interesting distribution um we can see
that there is interest in automation
uh manual design planning and design
always surprising to me that in 2021
we're still doing this
but of course we see this uh regularly
as well
well hopefully with these answers we'll
see uh you'll get some answers and more
clarity on the
the presentation i think now we without
further ado
i can bring in gift to present the
proximus case
uh and and show how how the use of
swampsof benefited the
proxima so here up to you now okay thank
you
kelly uh i'm indeed going to walk you
through
what i would call a basic setup of
komsoff at proxmos how we
and proxima's are using console it is
within my team
that we are using console and
already registers a couple of years and
i'm going to
show you how we are doing this
okay i'm going to start with basically
the same slide as
rough was showing but more specifically
a bit tuned
to what we are doing in proximize
because hey indeed
as seraph was saying you need a lot of
data
you have the concept calculator that
will calculate
the design for you but you need a lot of
input data
and you need also defined region
right you cannot just do that
randomly you need to have a region where
you want to
calculate your designing we call the
those regions
typically fiberhoods that's proxima's
terminology
and a fibroid is on average 3 000 living
units
respect to the data we are using all
kind of data in fact
and we are using off-the-shelf data
data that we have in-house in in
proximus
or that we can obtain from the
government for instance cartography
data we have also in-house processed
data so we calculate some of our data as
well
and we also use survey data and data
that is
gathered by our partners who are doing
the construction
and we do for instance in street survey
so we have a lot of data coming in we
have of course also the design rules and
the unit prices
those are you know typically defined by
proxy proximity so we have our own
design rules
and of course also our own unit prices
and that all goes in the mix in the in
the console
calculator and uh we typically do
and that's perhaps also very typical for
proximas
it just is not one goal one calculation
that we are doing
for a given five root now we are doing
different iterations
and we will go deeper into detail with
respect to that how we are doing that
it's just not one calculation but
different
iterations and what comes out of it are
designs plans a network
data and also what we are doing with
with that is we stored centrally
we try to consolidate whole data and
that is very interesting also to drive
other processes
and we'll come back later in the
presentation as well
on how we do that
um yeah but first of all
the concept process approximates i was
talking about doing designs on the level
of
fibroid on average 3000 living units
that is what i would call the designs
what you can see more on the right of
the screens the designs the high level
designs
hld but the story starts
even way before that and that's what i
called here on the slide first term
and national and that's basically
the first calculation or a very big
calculation that we are doing
in order to obtain figures to have
figures on the level of a business case
now what is also very interesting to
mention is that there is a strict
part that proximus is doing so proximus
is really in charge of using
console and designing the
fiber network and that a certain point
after the
high level design is done it is handed
over to the construction partner
and so proximizes in charge
of how the design will look and we are
actually
are doing the design as well the
construction
a partner is afterwards responsible
for the construction of it
but first look uh perhaps first take a
look at what is the first term
what is it what do we do with it
and basically i think in a lot of
companies it starts with the questioning
because you just don't do
fiber deployment like that it's not that
you say
on a certain day well okay let's let's
do final deployment
now you want to build a case you want to
yes
yes i think it's
worth mentioning indeed that when
confronted with with this question
what we often see is there's a great
dilemma
at this stage between the accuracy that
you need on the numbers and the speed
the time you get
to uh to produce those numbers and
often yeah it used to be that you needed
to make a choice
driven by a limitation in time how
accurate can you get those numbers
but nevertheless when you look at the
numbers patrick was also mentioning on
what amount of money you're putting in
and you don't want to get those numbers
wrong right i think you'll uh
you'll agree with me you know you wanna
be
you wanna be certain about it so yeah
tell us about how you
actually do that to get that right
balance between those two
well um basically i think
we started also uh very long ago with a
very high level business case
but we saw as well what what kumsov
could do
and and the level of accuracy it could
bring
and of course as soon as the finance
guys figure out that you can provide
very detailed figures they want that
those figures uh and then it's a
question of speed
and indeed we worked very hard the last
years to
to have those figures uh more and more
easily and more and more faster
but what's very important i think this
is indeed this is the accuracy
um because and that's that's the system
that we worked on
is is that we developed if i can get
to the next slide
yeah um because here the question is
for business case where you're going to
when when and where are you going to
start your deployment
we have six million homes in belgium
where
are the juicy bits and how how how are
you going to calculate that
and basically what we are doing is that
we said okay
we know the cons of the software and we
use the console
software on a level of five groups that
something that we we know
but do that same thing
but do that now 600 times divide the
country in 600 times and that's
basically what we are doing
and do 600 times what we call cons of
run and we choose to do that on on a
level because
with the copper we already divided
belgium in more or less 600 local
networks
and we basically are running a console
run
per local network we collect all that
data and we consolidate all the data
and out of it we have a huge number
of figures and numbers um
and but that is very valuable there we
can get
a very clear idea uh
on what it would cost to deploy a fiber
network
in the whole of knowledge
input data is the quality of the input
data there is
very important i think we are more or
less lucky in belgium that we have
a rather good quality of input data and
with that i mean
the cartography and with respect to to
the addresses the number of
what we call the demand points but
nevertheless
we can and we see differences between
regions
right we have to take that into account
um when you're doing this kind of
exercise you just
don't want to do that on your laptop you
need a server environment and that's
something that we learned as well you
need a server environment
you need software that will support
doing that
loading and unloading of data combining
data processing results
and even then it will i you don't have
it on on one day
it takes a couple of weeks to calculate
and it takes a couple of weeks to
process all the data
but it's well worth the effort uh to be
quite honest
because what we thoroughly do with this
data
is that okay we take this data further
it's not just like
we have network cost data because for
every little
square or whatever polygon there on
in belgium we have a network cost we mix
it with marketing data
with the same granularity number of
customers number of potential customers
number of potential revenue whatever
by combining that you can find
the juicy bits you can find the low
hanging fruit and that's basically
why we are doing the national run and we
call it the national
the first run uh and in fact it's
something that we will repeat
it's not something that we have done
once uh to have a business case
but it's a process that we repeat
in order to always have the the latest
data but it's again
i don't want to put you on the i don't
want to put you on the spot here but
something comes to mind i've been
involved in the past in in national runs
and national business cases
um and and there has been pains there
especially in government subsidized
programs but even though
um gaps with you know these national
runs from a technical level
uh combining technical and business case
and then the decision making process of
the the executives whether it's sea
level or higher
did this bring any value and and if you
can maybe
talk about how uh this positively
influenced
uh or not the decision-making process at
executive level is process well it's
kind of also very is simply on that and
the fact is that
the national run or simply the the name
the national run this is very widely
known within the company within
proxima's
and even at higher management they know
about comsoft and they know about
the national run and about the value
that it brings
so in that sense it's not just a little
exercise that we are doing
in a main corner but it's really very
well known
within the company and on all levels i
would say
okay so that's that's the first bit hey
that's in fact where
everything started with uh with with
a big calculation and where are we
getting the figures to do our
deployment our final deployment and that
we know where to start
but how are we doing this now on a
day-to-day basis okay because that's
and the second part the high level
designs
each of these that we do in order to
construct our fiber network
and basically i already talked about
that we are doing
this in different iterations we are
going over
a fiberhood and we are going to
calculate a fibroid
different times um we are calculating
feeding and distribution
so not only distribution but also the
feeding we are using different
layers of inputs demand points existing
infrastructure wall mount
trenching cartography
and by doing different iterations
you can increase your accuracy and the
quality of your design
and at the same time and we will see
that directly
you will get a view on how it is
changing how your design
is getting better first step this step
is a very important one is cleaning of
the input data
because even if your input data is okay
to say which has a certain quality
the input and the cleaning of the input
data is very important because
even a small error can have
significant effect on the outcome of
your design
so it's important to have good input
data
in the first part we start with in-house
data the second part what we call here
the 2a
we integrate street survey data so
that's data that has been
gathered by by the partner the
construction partner
of actual street uh addresses
updated information you will come so far
and then i think that's also very
important one of the iterations that we
are doing is in
is in involving the construction part
it's just not that we are doing again
our design
in our little corner i think it's also
important to involve the construction
partner in this process
so between stage what we call stage 2a
and 2b
we asked the construction partner to
give his feedback on the design that we
have made
and he can give some
you know points to consider or to change
and in the last iteration we can even
integrate
site survey data to have the most
accurate and qualitative design and
that's in fact that's that's the thing
that we want to do
have a very uh high quality design and
the best thing i think that we can do
that is doing that
in different iterations
um main takeaways from me but what i've
learned here
for us is that again i've said it
cleaning data is very important it takes
time
and in fact it takes the most time in
this process here because
just doing the console for run letting
the machine do the calculation
doesn't take that a long time
cleaning data takes time but it is
needed the better your data is
the better the result garbage in
curvature
so the opposite is also true very good
input very good output
and i think it's also very important
here that we involve the construction
part
in this process that he can take part in
the design process
that it doesn't the design at the end at
the 2 st
2c design it's all of a sudden a design
that we say to the construction partner
and now you have to construct this and
now i think it's important that he can
also have his say in this process
and that he can see how the design
evolves as well
so that way he is prepared as well
yes yes and well i would like to add
just here that
for sure this is not a specific
proximist problem and
the quality of data um it's the same in
every country
uh it is indeed sometimes a barrier you
need to
overcome when you want to introduce the
automation in the process
and therefore can sometimes be like okay
should we invest time in this
but as you rightly say uh here there's
so much
yeah things you gain afterwards uh from
uh from taking that stuff that it's uh
that it's crucial
and what i also have seen over the past
i would say
five six seven years is that there is
also
an important general um improvement
evolution in the general quality of data
patrick talked in the beginning about
digital native company objective
well if you look at the quality of the
own records
of a company like proximus
there is a continuous improvement that
really also contributes to uh
to to the process in in a lot of ways
and even
new things like lidar data where uh just
driving a van
automatically recognizing the street
survey or the uh
the existence of a street pole that
could be reused for uh for aerial cable
is things we've seen at certain
customers that that can actually be used
to further automate also the cleaning of
the data
so i think it's a challenge but but yeah
an investment worked
uh worth taking um and that that will
definitely increase the efficiency
uh in the end-to-end process yeah indeed
and it depends a lot of the
what is your basic data quality and you
can
indeed and enhance it with other things
like like
lighter and others but i think in the
budget case that we have
quite a good basic quality to start off
with
but that's also an advantage even if
there are differences per region
and it's something that we always that
we see as well
yeah okay here we have a question
yes yeah we do yeah i have a question i
have a question yeah
doing this design with with my team
which were we call by the way the
console team so
that's product placement i guess but
um and and yeah we've done
more last year more than than one
million homes
calculated in different iterations of
course
but less than five must be kidding
how many people all my desires and
quality assurance resources do we need
to do that what what do you think
yeah that's an interesting one because
like you guys said it's very effort
driven out whether it's
cleaning up of the data the input data
or whether you need to go
and collect some data and actually do
the designs after that
so yeah different choices could be more
than 30 between 21 and 30.
it could be all the way less than five
so it's interesting to see
a good distribution we see that maybe a
majority combine is is somewhere between
11 and 30
here in the number of resources
so would be curious to see what what was
the case with proximas
and if we're talking you know the
national run already it's we're talking
six million uh not just one million uh
but
maybe yeah we're talking about it yeah
we're talking about here the daily
operations and what we are doing
with in my team that using cons of how
we are doing
i didn't vote because yeah i know the
answer of course it wouldn't be
very honest to to do so um
i have a small team of four uh who are
doing this
and even to be quite honest not all four
of them
are doing full-time designs that comes
off
and because yeah we are also working on
automating
certain stuff and we are working on some
designers etc
but with less than four
we calculated more than one million
living units last year
um in different iterations it doesn't
mean that we have already calculated
one-sixth of badge but what is more
is that it's a very crucial step in the
fiber deployment
because every design that's why i
mentioned all also like there is no
pressure
no pressure on my team but every design
of the
brownfield fiber deployment is passing
through those four people right
so all the surveys all the simulations
all the data that's coming in
process through us and after us there
are
500 plus construction workers who are
waiting for us there is millions of
budgets to be spent
and we are just building a network that
will last more than 50 years so
no pleasure yes there is pressure of
course but hey
we did it last year like that
but we will see that we will progress
also i mean because it's
accelerating our deployment and this
will have an impact as well
on the team
um yeah i was talking about acceleration
because everything was going very well
is going very well uh
and and yeah up to the time that uh our
ceo
and you see his picture
had the idea like okay if i were
deployment well very well but uh
you need to go faster here's the
pressure
much faster and by the way do it cheaper
as well
right so okay still no pressure
um how did we tackle this one
uh when it comes of um
how we are using to to to optimize the
deployment cost how we are using console
and to optimize deployment cost
and the first parameter where we
worked a lot on was the design rules and
the design rules is one of the things
that we are putting into console
and in the calculator to build our
network
and the design rules are very important
in the way that they are determining how
your
design your network is going to look but
it is also very important in the sense
that they are determining
in a very important way the cost of your
network as well
and we are very busy at optimizing all
these variables uh
as you can see on the bar at the top i
think
more or less every year we have a new
iteration and newer desired rules
and we do that thanks to our designs
that we have done
with other design rules that we analyze
that we look at and how can we optimize
what can we do better
now we define they define new desirables
have a development comes of
a new version or new versions
it's getting more and more complex also
we started with wall mount and
underground
version 2 2.1 2 2.1
we are now going to uh even combine two
versions of underground together in the
same
fibrous wall mount underground version
two
underground version three we are going
to combine that
there are yeah i'll be already talking
about
doing ball mounts as well in the future
it's an evolution that continues it it
doesn't stop
it's continuous uh evolution and
looking at current designs analyzing and
defining what can be better
um we just don't do that for fun hey we
do that to optimize the cost because we
see also that different regions
benefit from different design rules and
we see that very well we are
we started our deployment in the city
centers we are now going more to the
suburbs
even more to rural areas now we see that
to
drive the the efficiency the cost
efficiency of your network deployment
that you need to adapt your design rules
on the other hand we know as well every
year new design rules
always introducing new designers it can
be a challenge as well
right for everybody who needs to work
with it it's always new
you have to learn and you have to adapt
and yeah i think and and i think that
rock already said that
uh once uh we have i think one of the
most complex
sets of design rules within proximize
um but yeah it's a benefit that you need
to take
it's it's it's a choice that you need to
make
in order to be cost efficient
it's sometimes technically a little bit
more complex but
it's still doable well and and if i can
just
add uh on on this part of the story uh
here i think one of the remarkable
things and the part of the success of
our
collaboration i think is definitely also
in the the manner of yeah cooperating
and a very tight
um and close collaboration between the
comms of experts and the proximus team
and
making these iterations and adaptations
work
uh as fast as possible implement them as
fast as possible so they can be
checked so definitely they're
subscribing to what potrik was already
mentioning as
uh we are really talking about
partnering and
working together in an ecosystem and
thinking together as well
it's not always just work working but
also thinking and
about what what can be better and how
can we evolve
and to have still a better system
um so the design rules is one thing to
do to get more
uh better deployment costs of lower
deployment because
uh analyzing the deployment cost is also
possibility and certainly something that
we are doing
because what's very interesting in this
this schematic
of what we are doing with comsoft is the
data now
we know that shapefiles designs that
something that construction partner is
wanting to have
but there is also a lot of data that can
be used
and we are usually on a continuously
basis we are doing calculations we
calculate
unit cost cost evolution cost per
network element cost per region
because all the data is centralized it's
very easy to
do so so we see how the cost is evolving
see what for instance if we have a
certain net if we
want to make sure
i'll say that otherwise if we want to
take certain actions
for instance we want to lower the price
of a certain network element
with all the data at hand we can
identify
which network element can be the most
interesting
to do an exercise to see what will be
the effect
if we the lower the price of a certain
network element
is a continuously improvement it's an
exercise that continuously is ongoing
and uh as we were already previously
seeing i think
the whole notion of doing console
calculations it's something that is
known uh a bit everywhere within within
the proxima's company
and it's a very very valuable thing to
have all that data
and to use that data i call it also
goldmine
[Music]
to find cost optimizations
and to find better ways to to
to deploy our network
i saw something move on my script
okay so cost is very important cheaper
we have a lot of data that we can
analyze but
we need to move faster as well and not
only this presentation but also
the fact that we need to deploy faster i
come back to this slide
and yeah the mantra was like okay we
need to double
the speed times two so still no pressure
um but we needed to get some help
and and uh in order to strengthen our
team
uh we uh got to jungo and
yungo is a console certified partner
who's working in the czech republic and
we were
at the record time i would say as well
we were able to
up staff my team with members of the
yungo team
in order to help us and to to
to get through that acceleration i think
we started
we're the first id to go to yungo in i
think
last year november in january we were
operational
i think that's that's a huge uh success
um if the tool is
uh what we are doing it comes off so
crucial
within the process of the fiber
deployment that we are doing
it's nothing more than logical that we
get also
inside of our company inside proxima's
official i.t support we also set up
a specific server in environment
and and and also the way that we are
working
proximize and comes off together has
been
uh getting more and more professional uh
over time
um and just to give some ideas if you
are talking about the server
uh if we are doing calculations on the
national run it's it's more than 30
calculators
that we are using it's terabytes of
storage
but it's a very powerful
machine indeed
i am taking it further because
uh console and everything that we've
seen up till now
is i would say the very traditional
thing the traditional thing it's a
calculator that
we are using to
design a network and to have some data
out of it
but we are more and more using the comms
of
data also outside
out of this process and we are exploring
more
new ways to use that data and we have
data
coming out of it and in fact
yeah we use it now to drive different
things
uh the console data is also used to
do contract awarding the very early
stage what we call
in the process stage one we can
calculate
a certain area or areas of cities
with conserve and that information is
handed over to the partners who want to
construct
for us so that they can get can get a
very good idea
what the the new work could be eh
and if we are to contract the warden
having the information from comsoff is a
valuable input
to give to future partners
the purchase order process so
every time if you going to deploy a city
parts of the city purchase orders are
issued
to our partners um then we are using the
console data
it's not again another database that we
are building or whatever
no we take the data out of comsoft we
want to construct these and these and
these fiber roots
take the data from console and as such
we are issuing
the purchase orders so it's a link
effect between price lists and
console data another link is when you
have your comps of data with all the
data per fiber mod
and you combine it with planning so
when you want to actually deploy in
in your fibers you can make forecasts
capacity forecast towards your partners
if that they can for instance
dimension their teams correctly or how
many teams they knew
they need for trenching how many teams
they need to
do wall mount and others you can do
material forecasting
because you know how many what your
quantities
are in a favorite thing when you know
when you want to do a fire grid
you can do a forecaster material and
also very importantly
the cost of data is also used to drive
our financial planning
and the same way if you know
when you wanted to deploy certain
favorites
you know what to do in five routes in a
certain
and in those five routes you can make
a very accurate financial
planning
uh it doesn't stop here of course it's
it's
um that we do the design rules they will
be extended we are still exploring new
ways to do
the to extend those design rules the
input data
we are still looking at ways how we can
enrich the data
server is involving and the integration
to
other processes is something that will
continue
as well wow
um bit of relax eh
after all that information i've come i
think rather uh
fast through everything but i kept the
timing which is also
important i think in order to have a bit
uh
time for q a um
some final thoughts and some final
relaxing uh
words when i think about
console or when i think about console
i think basically about three things and
that are important for us
uh for our company this first of all it
comes up
is the best designs that brings us the
bestest designs
the most optimal designs uh cost
efficient designs
and the way that we are using comes off
and we are evolving
and continue to evolve with console
is very fast it's very agile
and testimonialist is that we are
changing design shoes
almost every year and that we have
multiple versions of console
and the third one is perhaps a lesser
known
thing about comsoft is that beneath all
those
designs there is a very rich data
environment
that can be used to drive cost
efficiency
that can drive planning that can drive
also other processes outside the normal
i would say the back process and
planning engineering construction
process voila
i think i covered this yes i did
thank you very much uh thank you very
much for taking us
through all those different steps and
and as you rightfully said
uh it's an evolutionary party it's been
an
amazing journey over the past years
working together
and to get where we are now and and i
think if i can
have one take away from what you were
saying that
i found very powerful um it's that
that sentence when you showed and
mentioned that
the bill of material and and the details
and the knowledge you gain
out of that that's really a gold mine
for
the right decision making it gives you
the insights
you need to make sure you're uh you're
doing the right
uh steps in the rollout in the decision
making afterwards and i think that's a
very nice accomplishment
okay um so there's been
like a dozen questions already coming in
so anyone else in the audience still
wanting to uh to ask a question
you can still leave it in the in the q a
screen
we have some time to treat some of those
first of all
quite a practical one that came back a
couple of times um whether the the
recording
and the presentation will be available
uh afterwards uh
and yes that that's the case so anybody
registered
for the webinar will get access to the
material um so that's an easy one
i'll leave the difficult ones to answer
to the other
people so i'll pick up one here um
where there's a couple of questions
actually coming back on the topic of
street survey and and
site survey can you maybe explain um
briefly here's what what is also the
difference between those two
and what is the most important uh
updates that comes out of these surveys
that that
like what's the biggest difference that
those surveys bring
in the influence uh basically the
difference between street survey and
site survey is quite easy
now with the street survey we just walk
into the streets
and we call it a bit like we are
counting the ladder boxes
so we do doing an outside survey we
don't
do not enter any building
so that's basically street survey what
we get out of it
is that we get a very accurate survey
about
the number of living units
and and again in some regions it can be
very little difference between the
actual data that we have
in some regions it can be quite
substantial
it depends hey but that's a street
survey it's an outside survey
counting the letterboxes with the side
side of it
we are going inside building and that's
mainly to do a survey on
how we are going to construct and we are
talking not about
single dwelling units but we are talking
about new detailing units so apartment
buildings
and that's mainly to have an idea how we
are going to construct
the infrastructure on the inside but
what is also important and that's
typically on the chaotic way we are
building in belgium
that even in a site survey we can still
identify some extra living units or
some special things
and that's why we also add that to
our chain of information that we process
if i may add on the importance of the
survey we should not uh
underestimate uh the importance of that
step right because
it goes back to the importance of that
input data
that you were talking about and the most
accurate input data will provide you the
most accurate design
right we already talked about that but
sometimes again going back full circle
full circle to that dilemma that raf you
were talking about
speed versus accuracy which one should
we choose
we've seen in the past in many cases
where the site survey is a means to that
data quality end right that you want and
they
you know people bypass that step just to
get
digging in the street as soon as
possible but uh we know how
how uh how much boss can be
yeah because of that you know yeah we
want to avoid surprises at the end
and that's why we are putting a lot of
effort into all those
surveys and those iterations is just to
have
always a little bit better result and a
little bit more accuracy
um and it pays off to be quite honest
okay because the opposite is also true
a number of small number of
bad data can have a very big impact on
your uh
on your end result yeah
well then maybe jumping into that there
was also a question
whether um yeah it comes of tooling or
anything around that
also does some in automated data
cleaning
or data integrity checks um
is there any any experiences you can
share there
that's something that we try to develop
in-house
that we do indeed some
checks as i said also in the
presentation we also process our own
data
and there indeed we do also
some some checks about data integrity
and we try also to make some tools
in order to find uh i would say
inconstant inconsistencies and in data
yeah indeed we do
and and some questions here relate also
to the fact that of course we've now
talked a lot about the early stage high
level
simulation national run and high level
design
but what after that with low level
design
and the tooling in that part of the
process um if they are talking about low
level design or detailed design that's
something that is done
at the partner society so what we are
basically
producing or making is a high level
design
and that means that we have a design up
to the level of the cable
um and up to the level of the number of
fibers in the cable
that we know how many fibers are
connected to the other cable
but the detailed design which we are
when you are clearly going to design
that the the blue fiber in cable 7 is
going to the red
fiber on cable 29
that is done on the partner side and
that is done
uh in in the inventory system in fact
between those there is no uh link
yeah well and i can comment maybe as
well that we do have some
yeah construction partners of proxima is
also using some forms of tooling for low
level design
but not all of them as you leave them
free as you say
to use their own use for construction um
it's a choice of the
of the partner what the what tools they
want to use
uh maybe for you kelly um an interesting
question here that says
what size of network does it the do you
need
what makes sense to use automation tools
like console
is there a minimum size that's a very
good question
um actually uh of course like any
software uh you know you need to have a
training you need
there is a a period that you need to
dedicate to
to train your your resources to use the
software so indeed
uh with automation it goes without
saying that you know the bigger
your your scope um the more valuable
automation becomes because it just
covers that much
more in scope so um i i wouldn't uh
put a tag on it necessarily i would
always say if you do have an ftth scope
contact us let us know what your scope
is and there's always a
a way to to discuss i would say though
if you
you're starting out with a very small
scope one thing that is very interesting
is
talking about our design partners we
have design partners that are already
fully fledged capable
of taking on those designs and instead
of maybe investing
in that amount to bring in a new
automation software you can turn to
a certified design partner where they
can do those designs for you
and really help you out but i in the end
i would encourage
uh everyone to just contact us and we
can discuss
on a case by case i think it also
depends on the the complexity of your
design rules
if you can keep your design rules very
standard
or very simple i think you can have very
quickly uh benefit
of automating it through yeah
and so unfortunately your complexity of
the rules has been very high
with all these combinations so you
needed some size but two million
homes and even now four million homes is
more than enough to get the benefits out
of it uh
for sure so i see we've run through our
time we've also treated uh
part of the questions but we can also
take some other questions
uh directly with the people asking them
so i think we can wrap it up for now
i'd like to thank all our speakers and
all our attendees
for your attention and i hope it was
useful and that you learned something
out of it
and for the rest i hope to see many of
you
hopefully soon again physically at some
fiber events
across the world rather than too many
webinars in the future but for now
take care and see you soon bye
you